Seaweed didn’t exactly come into play during
those “make your own ice cream” science
experiments you probably did in elementary
school, but it is sometimes used in the making
of commercial ice cream.
No, it isn’t just in seaweed-flavoured ice
cream, either.
Seaweed is actually used as a type of thickening
agent for ice cream.
Technically, the substance usually used to
thicken the ice cream is called “agar”
or “agar-agar.”
The name comes from the Japanese word for
“red algae.”
It was discovered in 1658 by Minora Tarazaemon,
a Japanese innkeeper who supposedly left extra
seaweed soup outside overnight.
It was winter, and the substance froze.
Tarazaemon noticed in the morning that it
had turned into a sort of gel when it thawed
again.
Whether that’s exactly how Tarazaemon discovered
it or not, it was later found that after first
boiling seaweed, repeated thawing and freezing
makes a pure, gelatinous substance perfect
to use as a thickening agent.
It’s likely that the process was picked
up by the Dutch in the 17th century and later
spread to other East Indies ports.
Today, agar is used in a variety of processed
foods as an emulsifier or binding agent.
Not every country or company uses it; some
use carrageenans instead, which is made from
certain red seaweeds.
The use of different substances is based purely
on preference and availability of resources.
For instance, during World War II the availability
of agar was low, so many companies switched
to using carrageenans instead and stuck with
it even after agar became more widely available
again.
(A similar thing happened with Twinkies, where
during WWII bananas were in short supply,
so Hostess switched to using a vanilla cream
filling, rather than banana cream.
The vanilla cream filling turned out to be
much more popular, so they never switched
back to banana cream filling, though kept
the banana-like look to the Twinkie anyways.)
But you make homemade ice cream with just
milk, sugar, and a bag full of ice and salt—so
why is a binding agent needed in the production
of commercial ice cream?
The basic components of ice cream are fat
(usually from milk), sweeteners, air, ice
crystals, and “other solids” which includes
non-fat milk solids and various flavours (like
bits of cookie).
When the ice cream liquid is prepared, often
an emulsifier and stabilizer must be added
to keep all the ingredients together and improve
the texture.
That’s where the seaweed comes into play.
Most commercial stabilizers these days are
vegetable gums—that means agar, carrageenan,
or something like Xanthan gum (derived from
bacteria found in cabbage).
These stabilizers keep ice crystal growth
small by immobilizing the liquid in the ice
cream—sort of by acting like a sponge.
Larger ice crystals, caused by too much liquid
in the ice cream, will make the ice cream
feel grainy if a stabilizer is not used.
The stabilizers also help keep the ice cream
from melting too quickly so that you can enjoy
your ice cream for a longer amount of time
on a hot day.
That said, more stabilizers do not equal higher
quality ice cream.
Quality ice cream typically contains more
fat and less air, while lower quality ice
cream substitutes a higher quantity of
stabilizers
for fat, and often contains more air molecules.